el príncipe felipe pues es una figura
que puedo tratar de tú a tú a la reina
como ninguna otra persona en el mundo
debido como lo señalaba la corresponsal
a sus 73 años de matrimonio realmente
tiene un papel importante dentro de lo
que ha sido la formación de una nueva
dinastía en la dinastía windsor él tuvo
él no tenía apellido tenía el apellido
grecia después adoptó el bate en verde
su madre su abuelo materno se lo cambió
por no un bat en debido a que su tío
lord mountbatten lo acogió y finalmente
tras el matrimonio cambia o deja más
bien que sus hijos tengan el apellido
windsor entonces este también es un
papel importante debido a que fue un
militar exitoso participó en la segunda
guerra mundial en la batalla de creta
estuvo en el desembarco de las tropas
inglesas en sicilia estuvo también
presente en la firma del armisticio de
los japoneses con los aliados en 1945 al
final al final
la segunda guerra mundial y durante
todos esos años de la guerra mantuvo una
correspondencia con una niña de 13 años
que había conocido teniendo el 18 casi
19 que sería luego su compañera durante
tantísimos años su majestad la reina
isabel segunda bueno se dice que el
príncipe felipe tuvo un rol esencial
para modernizar la realeza británica
puede explicarnos en qué consistió su
aporte en este aspecto
pues realmente el aporte del príncipe
felipe para mostrar pues una figura de
matrimonio joven que se va formando que
va creando su familia ellos se han
casado en 1947 al finalizar la segunda
guerra mundial muestran pues cómo va a
ser esa economía de la posguerra nacen
sus hijos en 1948 carlos en el 50 anna
en el 60 andrés y en el 64 eduardo una
familia pues que no obstante las
distancias se consideran también como
modelo de lo que debía ser la sociedad
inglesa y esto dio cierta forma también
a la modernización de la monarquía
frente a una monarquía mucho más
tradicionalista de 'jorge sexto quien
había tenido que solucionar los
conflictos precisamente por los
escándalos de su hermano enrique octavo
cuando se casó con una dama divorciada
norteamericana la señora wallis simpson
duquesa de windsor y pues un poco más
atrás el abuelo de la reina la bisabuela
la reina victoria' que es
todo el siglo 19 prácticamente con la
emperatriz victoria y la reina pues
entonces llega como tercera monarca
cuarta monarca después de sus
antecesoras isabel primera maría
estuardo victoria y luego isabel segunda
bueno pero justamente ya que usted habla
de la reina ante la partida al príncipe
felipe preocupa el estado de salud de la
monarca que sigue fungiendo como jefa de
estado a sus 94 años qué significa esta
pérdida para isabel justo cuando el país
enfrenta el postre sí y además la
pandemia como 19
pues realmente
la reina que siempre dijo que felipe era
su roca su fuerza y su sostén va a ser
algo que la afecte no solo en su salud
sino también sentimental y anímicamente
llega el momento de considerar
eventualmente para la reina o la
abdicación en favor de su hijo o la
renuncia de carlos para continuar con
una monarquía que ha sido en cierta
forma renovada con la presencia de
enrique y de kate middleton los duques
de cambridge que son pues hoy en día
como un modelo también de familia a
seguir frente al escándalo también de
harry miguel quien únicamente ha enviado
un pequeño mensaje diciendo nos vas a
hacer falta
bueno pues agradecemos a hernán olano
por su opinión acerca del fallecimiento
del príncipe felipe